Sunday
oh you know some things some good things
some bad things
so attentive viewers right off the bat
will notice something weird mary has a
psg I have the five five six assault
rifle
we got renee longer mean you have it we
essentially uh [ __ ] up we played about
two and a half hours over the weekend so
we could like pump resin alive out we
felt bad that we missed the weekend
prior but there was audio issues so we
are just starting from where we would
have started we just have a couple
weapons that won't make sense if you've
been watching now we get to go on ultra
mode so switch over to your game no
looks yet and then just get my super
hair paranoid about the audio oh cool
this is the problem is because we're
playing two-player we are using a mics
monitor both to monitor the recording
but then also he plays on it so we just
switched the inputs so if something goes
wrong with the recorder we can't tell
until we're done playing and we lost the
decent amount of time but that's okay
we're back
you have five seconds full three two one
some of the egg first aid spray
I'm good shape I'd rather have that time
backs in an egg oh man
it needs good Rosario [ __ ] up by
something uh what's this very okay
coming out okay sir my butt
Oh also because this might come into
play
v-mon is here
my dog and a chair he is right behind us
there is sleeping behind us so he's got
lots of water though got lots of water
he's good to go
he's a happy dude alright so I remember
this the other thing that sad is that
[Music]
technically I played the usual dose
departures so oh wait we did this
together because if one of us died then
those were to be both sides so let's
just do it together
I hate this part why do you kick them I
don't know you piss off
yeah I find this section to be
interesting in terms of games but it's
like difficult to Brighton oh ho ho I
like it I feel like it's different
difficult to prove that that was worth
it in a real world scenario I know we
like take a lot of we have like oh my
god we have like a lot of leniency with
these games in terms of realism but like
that weapon is so not helpful
no I mean like like oh that should kill
him you know I haven't done my behind
the back one and I'd like to can I do
that now uh yeah break up next thank you
but yeah you can okay well done the guy
I would i wasn't intentional i think is
a little loud the gameplay already on it
I have a shotgun I missed it
oh man I got hurt oh no I want to it
alright however clear throats needs
slitting I wish you could rip their
throats like I macGruber roof [ __ ] girls
your name
nope wouldn't hurt you or would it um no
I've shot many of things here you
oh well there did well they're super
dead oh dear that with explosive arrows
listen I might need some ammo okay
shotgun be good yeah or hand them all
right let me do it let me do it
I'm not we're bad not risking myself
prettier in China
that's where you and I here with your
gift I got [ __ ] up okay there's a lot
of guys your backup where the [ __ ] are
you I'm coming
get that knees oh damn okay Rashida okay
I'll get that down machine gun right no
I do not I'll give it to them don't
worry
whoa who shot where's that coming from
oh I see wood [ __ ] oh man I am out of
ammo [ __ ]
all right I have five bullets all right
I'll don't wait something to kick this
dude no
here's I'll take my shot himself right
give you if you give me a red herb I can
combine with my green okay thank you
sweet for this got one emblem teach you
more all right let's go down ocean I'm
sure here where you came from there
yeah we good not doing so hot
oh sure eyes got laser - whoops I might
have to use the red and green right now
me well when you're here wait for me all
right heads up heads up I go again oh
yes I mean there's a little safety nook
nothing wrong with the baking up the
good forget look good it okay
handgun ammo why'd you take handgun ammo
I need it
oh yeah I forgot that hand got it
finally people are recommending it right
here - I'll just give you something um
ah double laser I thought that I just
wait let me kill this dude will this
matter help so you know that's a
shortcut just shoot him I didn't know
you could do that or not
alright sweet you should be saying oh
I'll keep it hold on once you pass that
there's the other one
yeah give her a rifle can you see him uh
yeah we know he's not there if they get
up on the far side and can deal with
this lately I don't see and that's why
my way to have on these guys what I'm
burning yeah go go go good laughs right
here okay good okay good good guy go so
anyway alright goes here - hey I'm not
gonna get em fighters oh wait goes here
too
okay coming we're gonna go get these
he's going to get me nope [ __ ] I'll give
you got em oh oh na Milan let's go fast
[ __ ] I'm gonna wait here we're gonna
make it
high back to the beginning okay a lot of
students there's some dudes over here
you want to stay here in rifle okay
oh I forgot is a vlog on
let's rifle psg PSO GG more like it
not good
um coming to help you prep bird that's
not a bird a bug a bird
ma'am the shotgun shells with alright do
those or more it's back toward the
lasers kind of we've activated the laser
the laser oh right they come again [ __ ]
you no biggie rap shotgun I have I have
a I have a grenade today yeah yeah
punch them
[Applause]
ah all right I've been extra money can I
take you can go to rounds sure I'm doing
okay oh wait there's pops over here we
got pops over here Pat come getcha pop I
don't know what this character is it's
I'm the pot and my character is the pot
man good thing I saw that machine I'm on
your screen come get your pot pots are
gone now sweet okay we're good shape up
through this little faster than last
time
ha that's lots of that um toxins you
want to just wait here and I'll go get
him now there's a lot there's a
proximity bomb over here I don't need it
um we're coming back up this way there's
machine gun ammo Oh work I want to go
get the other emblem quick but okay I'll
please come on
seriously you're making me educated but
come up this way I don't know when I get
laser and I'm gonna lat Oh close there's
nuts everywhere man
oh no
[Music]
oh come on wise you're not doing it
[ __ ] Olivia well it kinda reminds me
of MXC there's this ah that was during
the part where it's not a laser here
here here oh [ __ ] this part stops I'm
not [ __ ] going and then ha actually
you know what that's probably I do wait
there I'll go kill him
can I see him no idea where is he he's
behind up the wall
idiot good thanks
anyway an MXC for those who don't like
Romanian acronym most extreme
elimination challenge challenge they
have they have this one where it's like
a mountain and you have to run and dodge
a ball because you can do oh sure
oh I remember this somebody came after
me yep
Thank You cover I didn't give it off yet
memorizing it back okay I'm just I'm
checking my six here kind of shot
through your body and filled them p.m.
oh yeah
are they all dead now Jana the green
herb those ones but there's more no
we're done over here we're done
some assault kicking people all these
rifle I'm over here [ __ ] integrator
figure this out
oh are you too full nope got it
[ __ ] Expo I'll get on the way down from
them big dude coming towards you
webbing sorry now the sky emblems in my
shot I gotta um [ __ ] I can come help you
but I might be ditched I'm parched
I wasted four handgun bullets to bring
you directly I'll just say no thank how
many things just you owe me know you're
coming
I owe you my think oh my god I'm in a
lot of trouble like physically Dan this
guns inaccurate but I like it
I have Oh a lot uh problems here I have
health and I have ammo right um rightful
okay alright I'm good what do you need
smells good okay alright all three
emblems no more lasers we've deactivated
the lasers the laser what are you
quoting are you quoting anything you're
just saying it I'm just saying Malave
similar workaholics episode when they I
am an asset or know that you didn't you
want to get those things at the Pops or
did you already get another purchase or
splat that's where I'm going right now
it might disappear by now I know that's
why I told you get the PAC's margining
arm got it alright sweet it's a weird
name for it should be [ __ ] me mine I
would imagine I agree Oh tapped your
little thing there
all right
emblems have been inserted puzzle done
looks like wait oh we can't get this
last time oh worth it with a diamond
it's a diamond I know where you hid the
diamonds golden face
or was it where's your dog yearning for
escape a little bit yeah much like all
of us come life wait isn't there one
above us right now - wait there's one up
here at that and sometimes if you've
never man
[Music]
oh yeah I remember we died a lot more
lasers I'm seeing a theme unravel they
should just call this chapter laser is
an acronym chapter with lots of lasers
stop that
do you notice it's an acronym and I'm
not joking you know how scuba is an
acronym self-contained underwater
breathing apparatus laser is too
apparently I always forget what it is
it's like light accelerated something
vaping no I'm nexor serious okay
energy reg things come on zapping energy
ray not it cool just going to go turn
this one get behind me so you don't die
I'm good I got it sure yeah I definitely
or not no what are you doing that's not
it that's not it
I'll be like super safe over here but
let go of it that you're gonna get fried
I will get where I am
get behind the pillar um nope I got it
base I hope it burns you secretly what
is anything up on that platform before
you cross over the side
now you can't I can't I can't get over
there shove off there nothing there nope
come on lay there for it
you creep in a t-shirt jeans I don't
[ __ ] care
all right I'm going to knock this down
so you know all right that's there
that's there there's one over here I can
knock down okay ah I want to buy me all
right okay
good right Oh tell me that are there I
got to get this one I'm gonna go up here
I don't think anything can kill me on up
here and this safety nut no I'll do it
then I was rubies all right stay up
there okay
yes you're going left and there's one
more room and this is one you have to do
want to turn one of them before you
actually connect it with the lasers
it's hot in here in this room in this
room in this little real room that we're
in live streaming's studio yes yes
probably why C Mon so quiet
is he okay bed well there breed can ov
that breed can overheat so I do you need
to show him on the camera at some point
maybe later what do you say I'll do it
at the end all right if you actually
sticks around for the end of these
videos never this chest
yeah don't please don't there's no point
it'll just bring spiders or whatever but
there's treasures in the room there's
nothing here - oh I just came out anyway
over here okay on the ground
nothing nothing nothing yeah I guess
they don't give you very much do they
look at this guy
what an idiot I bet you say you'd have a
bad day that's a good joke I'm going to
turn this one first
wait I'm not dating is not touching the
lazy guys gonna the [ __ ] much he had a
turn
so we're just kind of turned me that one
that one and I'm just hanging around
that one's better should be almost
offset all right it should be good you
want to turn that one over use your
laser to tell me which laser to laser
yeah okay
all right go right whoa every little
disease revisited every now and then I
wanna [ __ ] yeah well tell that to uh
Rodin band from old school [ __ ] me oh
[Music]
sweet
[ __ ] this room let's go flowers pink
sweet that's the end of that chapter
are these for me Cristiano Kristin dumb
[ __ ] in heaven
[Music]
gotta love you
okay Chris but such a thing is overkill
how can you survive underground good
question when their Sun pouring in above
them these are no ordinary flowers
wait
Briella of course what
what I'm gonna do I don't know it
doesn't look like anyone's been around
for a while they're working to try to
keep this place a secret some of this
equipments got the try so logo on it
there's lots Pickens don't do two S's
nice continuing on us we've got some
things we can hello alright got a really
upgrade some [ __ ] oh how much the dime
at four thousand and nine nice upgrade
oh right someone was like when will
marry learn that she can sell all sold
all good for me thank you
I do read the chat and I learn oh no I
don't want to sell that I was god damn
egg in my santouri night
sweet and good can you give me know why
do you have Magnum you don't even have a
magnum can have your mag mental about
[ __ ] what the Desert Eagle thing is for
sale l Hawks I don't know what that is
hang on is this a new rifle that's
better than my rifle that's one you have
oh good
whoops sorry give it to Mike what's so
good about the L Hawk that's powerful
it's not uses of Magnum and I had them
oh I have a lot of money um great [ __ ]
okay I do not of money I recommend your
handgun and shotgun probably let you use
most well not if I'm gonna get a new you
know new what you already have good
shotgun in hand oh I thought you meant
my handgun I did oh she just got that
handgun I just got that rifle I know but
you also that's a new handgun just sent
money buying that he's gonna hang up I
spent money on to vest yeah I know that
somehow like this is going to max out
pretty soon it maxes out at 4:30 yeah
but you might as well you could pick up
a lot of hand guy animal you're not
spending money all right you know you're
by the time you use it it will be done
with the game fast what is this whatever
because my answers but obviously there's
a connection here with umbrella
unless never a good sign we can worry
about this later first we need to find
out I seen emblem you're right let's see
we can together all right dig up some
all right good job what's going on here
aha document stairway to the Sun Angie
[Music]
what are you doing I'm reading a
document war as they say allora I've
been watching master of nonsizi too Alan
well Mickens okay lick them stick them
right that's not going here again where
did you go documents assorted Tendo
grenade cool
what are you doing in here girl Nevin
Hannah got a machine gun ammo
don't feel like reading flowers
they must be presenting these flowers to
make something this is the facility from
the picture forgot about it
we finally did
shotgun shells around the table somehow
I don't think these are for Mother's Day
I say weird most they just happened what
last Sunday two Sundays ago honey was
recent yeah an email to an acquaintance
more we got to go out and get smashed
look at Saturdays for the boys oh my god
look it looks like a first person
shooter except the dumb transferrin on
my screen I'm right it does nobody can
like that you can though Oh somebody did
here all right
the foxy mom's making a little sleeping
mess behind us you so cute
look
looks like he was torn apart by animals
not a good way to go Rex shot these
goats I found you hate it yes I did hate
it don't shoot any animals hey hey what
oh there's potential zombies you're bad
persons never do it real the person who
shoots animals like more likely to like
be a homicidal maniac hey can you get
the screen herb no okay wait here oh
because I was going to say I have this I
have half a green herb and I could give
it to you we could combine but we can't
problem solved so you got power
everybody wins
laughs
[ __ ] you
Wow
[Music]
so like shirk this she uses her whole
body when she turns yeah she goes
alright
redder sweet okay let's figure this one
out all right uh what would be best you
know what okay I'm just gonna be doing
oh my god
getting rid of my excess here's a a K
over here you already have it yeah well
I don't have room for it all right I got
the better I Saul rifle from like
Junior's down the road three chapters
hang on all right let's kill some of
these are there were more of them killed
thank God that was all of them and there
won't be any more that was a close one
I am a smart man come on turn go go go
no breach clear okay so walk slowly me
oh [ __ ]
okay okay coming back to you hold on
hold on I got a I got a surprise for you
so we have a proximity line yeah I just
burned some with some things though [ __ ]
come to this side did we always kill all
of them ah might not be worth it there
are a lot maybe should go through the
doors and this is not good oh they're
nopales fear I think um she's not going
I'll get shotgun glue me that I mean I
guess look through this door we're in a
corner I don't like it I'm begging fight
all right I placed approximately mine go
come back to play okay you're wasting
shotgun shells no but I'm walking to
this I mean there's one left
well the other one just he's coming
toward you
Kiln do you need assistance
oh I should have kept that bomb down oh
that's [ __ ] I was behind the door I
gotta heal I really need your help
yeah I couldn't get there let's keep
running now on inside again it's on the
corner really does then I can put the
proximity mine down should I know just
ready Gus I'm not using these grenades
and it's taking up a slot just sure get
rid of quick yay good thing there
weren't any more of them well let me put
that proximity mine down second so what
if you oh I see
can you shoot them from here no no no
what did that lover do it turned on the
light you could see them in advance and
know what's about to happen to you um
I'm just gonna sprint and then play
footage okay wait okay yeah don't run
and I'm not gonna kick open the door wow
this is a very different way to do this
well I was also wondering why they said
that it's not a hint at something master
here no careful thanks Sheila
Chella Shayla they're coming now
yeah I thought go put it down if he
boxes though it's worth it hey no no
we're not even gonna fight them I'm
getting this animal get the shotgun
cells we're here quick come quick
herecome oh [ __ ]
what press it oh we got ya brothers now
I should put it down right man well
shoot somebody
Mary crying get away okay stop let them
hit it but a minute there we go sit
around a bunch of them yeah
not so grand about your friend oh that's
you
well I was more just go bro button
button button we just do shout down to
the elevator oh he's so cute you think
it's gonna be no fun full um I think I'm
also go why oh this part okay I didn't
know that
mr. pod
you
the pictures to wait that means Joe my
beard yeah
[Music]
Oh what happens done like a major
Gillian Valentino turning human life
into this yeah I've seen the movie so I
said this remind me of it subside I'm
gonna have one
elevator will stop in case of frostbite
you know when you to tell if batteries
are empty you can just drop them then if
they like they can land on no I'm not
kidding
come on penny Chris must be kidnapping
people from all over the world to
experiment on that's a bit far-fetched
crap why people the bed
oh [ __ ] I didn't I hate [ __ ]
beautii's
why the [ __ ] was that ever a thing in
games it still is about anyone who's put
them in a game alright calm god I hate
them they're fun we're skipping the [ __ ]
and we're not we're skipping the
cutscene stop taking them is why'd you
take a machine-gun em what are you doing
I just wanted to see how you would
handle it not well all right I'm going
hurry up no do not do that oh you're
being annoying do you really need that
you need the green urbanos excellent way
I'm gone okay really all right
let's touch bad this [ __ ] use l2 and r2
at the correct time of those two here
comes
dodged
okay we wrap
shoot is on alright wait spot some told
I wasn't shooting some sold sweet got it
now go Dimmick Rene I do oh good thing
you did get that I know you're actually
thinking I know uh I have to I don't
know
suck on this yeah well calling it
that's rig up a couple of green herb
Phillips is over here it's got a brain
exposed over here ah
or should I focus on these bulb things
the arm things did whatever shooting
time and labor the other grenades keep
its closing its brain even more he's
down he's now given another grenade you
know
sweet
oh I got a Henry right here sweet good
that works out
okay this dude is just being [ __ ] and
going now we got to go separate ways
we're not getting it done right now are
you breaking up with me Chris this is
probably a bad time but I think we've
just become friends more than romantic
lovers and I need something someone that
can fill a critical void in my life
otherwise I'll just probably mess down
and it's ugly both got their own stereo
obsessing bees yeah brain exposure
maximum BAM [ __ ] and piss oh [ __ ] you
choose in the wet in the brain brain to
face face oh not in the bulb where it
goes now actually yeah you can still do
that in the movies little son mmm yeah
[Music]
see what fast little crab is named
[ __ ]
Brook he knocks me off balance
Oh
stop moving down [ __ ] him
do you hear you a little bit sweet
yeah now be dead speaking of genitalia
his mouth looks suspiciously sexual you
know that I mean I'll initiate a lot of
the things in Resident Evil have done
that before remember in was it three
there was like that Viney thing and it
was all like vaginas like like gal de
maxi Joe
I'm breathing
he hardeneth bleep suit he farts all the
time yeah
I don't think dogs have the ability to
control part like people perhaps fingers
they have fingers let's check city Mon
come here that I don't think they can
show me your apartment but I don't know
if it fits like a muscle thing or if
it's like they have no reason to because
holding in your fart is a social thing
he doesn't care societal thing yeah like
holding in your heart is a learned trait
Axela like if you didn't care about what
anyone thought of you when you just fart
as soon as you need to do yeah
have you seen a Swiss Army knife no that
moves about not really that part of it I
sound in this area
it's like luckily I guess it's closed in
there not use remission you should be
there's nothing here will ruin your life
no way
[Music]
she's lying
do you know something time we get some
answers there's just like this whole
game is about them being like what is
going on and they're like you'll find
out soon enough and then it's like end
of the thing hey I'm so sure because we
died that second time you sell some
stuff nothing itself sweet I'm ready
actually captain Han got analyzed like
nothing kind of me Ben no you have 83
were hanging around 27 shotgun shell
like I kind of need it well you do need
it more than I did with all right I'm
good do they shoot more people as you
like run away going wait what if that
thing is this is this the one where I
use a [ __ ] ton of grenade rounds because
then I'm gonna need to buy grenade
rounds remember you know what I'm
talking about
sure you can get rid of those three
hanging around so I give those to me as
well I kind of want those okay then
don't bring the grenade launcher you're
an angry elf just 60 seconds those
explosive rounds seem nice they're
really [ __ ] expensive let me go with
you know what I'm worth it I'm going to
buy these explosive rooms and I'm going
to give you these even though you
complain a lot and I give these to me
and then I still not enough room um
probably get rid of those two rifle
rounds probably what about this help you
have to health we need three help yeah
cool I'm ready let's go everybody wins
good job I just remember a scene come oh
it's not the same with you I know it's
the mine you're thinking of moves got us
we'll be there
and almost guarantee she sent that bo w
to eliminate us you can ask her about
that
and about jealousy fine I bet you she'll
tell me everything probably like a James
Bond bad James Bond villain although in
the most recent today's bonus poet that
like kind of villain explanation
happened which I didn't like the most
recently I love Skyfall and I love
Casino Royale I did not like the other
to Daniel Craig did factor I thought was
bad
is there a new one the newest one is
Spectre I did not like it
oh wait I don't know if I want that
machine gun come on yeah no okay maybe I
can get through here
wow this part [ __ ] cover-based
shooting its [ __ ] I'm going what
alright I'm thinking about like what I
was going to wear tomorrow
[Music]
why hurry up they throw [ __ ] at a
OOP keep your stupid head out
this is so Gears of War what's happening
right now
Rep okay
there's a box
hmm being very cool about giving us lots
and lots of ammo right now I actually
can't take this I'm like maxed out those
[ __ ] egg let me use a welcome back
bro [ __ ] hey who's my grenade quick
I'll go up at any second
roof this is the wait
be right back all this boxes back here
you miss - I don't need anything else
rep machine gun ammo I got shot em I'm
dying gonna get the sample for some of
them I'm dying
it tells me that pretty plainly on the
screen there you go
why's your good thought you didn't know
any better because you weren't coming
into English doesn't sound like me I'm
just caught in this dire situation you
are not gonna get done that guy threw a
grenade it I was going to do that next
biker thing didn't work out hello
getting stomped so you got a rather cool
[Music]
there's a red herb over there I already
got oh okay cool come on come on come on
rich
it's a wall I know that looked like a
concrete wall that camera angle there's
this like recovery period after you
swing the knife and the steam that
wasn't forward if a bit agitated watch
it
is it still alive I can hear it nope hi
- aka what's going to do the top oh oh
alright I was getting money yeah I just
want a lot yeah couple of them oh oh oh
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] up oh god I'm in a lot
of trouble
all right you actually mom wait I
thought we did not panic
I didn't know you did Anna Coren down
inside you were like no yeah I said
calmly that no you're not a [ __ ] he
was shooting me
Oh [ __ ] me up dad I'm gonna use
that's where you're at
I'm coming alright hold on and
[Music]
there's little girl
yeah oh no not for guys they're
everywhere actually perilous trip oh we
are stupid
we're stupid people shotgun shells
machine gun ammo get the shotgun shells
over here I'll take my what
alright I mean you know you can carry
these extra ones alright Anna I can't
you're full of shotgun shells I mean you
know [ __ ]
whatever mm-hmm all right cool
um all right no I just wish that up like
that up
I think about fights coming up probably
so many basement levels
[Music]
I wonder who either did I just stop
thing his name in everything
Fenella a fine axela how are you doing
it fella
I thought he was dead that's mr. Albert
W you only won the world named Albert am
I missing something
did we forget like something earlier and
I know games I alluded to definitely
being Albert Wesker can we as well I am
full okay I have I am also full here's
some liquors I have a lot of Michigan oh
all right unfortunately no we need that
cuz I have a red err umm can you maybe
just throw your incendiary or discard
here incendiary grenade really a red and
green arms way more hmm oh wait wait
wait wait
will that even no that won't help that
won't help at all
okay let me don't use that when when we
run out of more ammo war combined [ __ ]
these futures what do shave liquors
said did that happen to open up any
animals he'll cinnamon I know I used all
my good gun once I should have no no I
just have a lot of machine gun I'm off
on it 75 all right yeah 42 they came
from here
get on the ground
rep behind you
RiRi yeah but I got a bunch I wish we
had been Cindy hurry grenade gotta
reload quickly
I need your have a good beer a [ __ ] you
got me my shotgun yeah I'm gonna shot
him
[ __ ] coming
talking
um yes cool
can you give me that green herb starting
to line it with my red oh sure here you
go friends yeah sweet look at dang you
should really I should always reload
before I take em oh I didn't think about
that
alright next time look at like the
armory on your body grenade launcher is
my private machete
oh I'm not [ __ ] around not to mention
the two biggest guns of all Chris
Redfield me in my mid other part you
remember this you remember that game we
got far but and then we lost it on I'll
talk about it any longer offer viewers
information I spent all Sunday here I
was here all cetera to for a separate
project so I'm not happy either
alright crap we felt like we owed it to
people since we missed the weekends
prior
with all these guys like their worker
gears just a construction other
camouflage we're not going to desire all
right I want to kill these cross the oh
[ __ ] forever no you probably more they
have done
I'm going oh my god
you with the only when you get a chance
to you what's that I might use that red
and green no no wait until you're yeah
okay that's throwing grenade so I'm just
going to keep moving I might have to use
that hit otherwise to split up I'm I'm
[ __ ] good go go go go
Phyllis - oh you guys throwing this [ __ ]
Oh for [ __ ] sake that was a huge
amount of my life
can you yeah you can give that guy thank
you because she was a blind possible oh
why can't I take cover here look at the
dead guy it's still long to die
ah thank you
oh that was Magnum do you come it's
beautiful
oh is that you or me neither someone for
something you guys a real a-hole I don't
see anyone neither
well obviously someone's doing it yeah
who's flashing us getting really
annoying to all there's a red herb we
must pack there isn't there
oh I see he's way up there I gotta reset
all right I was going sure he right yes
we get that better bow [ __ ] it how much
keep going we're doing well yeah
everybody's on the rail so he okay what
is the purpose of the facility up here
there's explosive barrels just going
into a furnace what is that from
gameplay perspective I get it Mike
you're doing that thing where you think
too much sweet oh I knew you were going
to start doing it here we go remember
how this oh wait hang on a mo how to
take that
yeah [ __ ] the green herb here that red
air but about helpful
so I actually really didn't need it okay
all right hey didn't kill that guy up
there I'll kill a cow you want to you
want to go first want me to hit him in
the crotch I'll go okay no fear
I just go up the rail same thing but try
to shoot those in advance so you don't
die where does that guy know you should
be good actually I'm coming oh that
sucked me up pretty bad um [ __ ] yeah I
should have done I don't don't go out
there yet hon let's kill you guys quick
yeah go quickly perform or come out I'm
gonna get the shotgun shell looking for
you second oh my god I need your help
you get up here now okay just get on the
rail sweet
a lot of clothes I know I'm just
exploding it before got to it was good I
was busy with a dude cool sounds like
that's it Kate alright well I didn't
know where we got middle Norris it
didn't go great better better
nope hang on you want that yeah yeah you
do
sweet I'll take the en send oh okay
if you want this gun you can take it
this time actually I guess that is bonus
you can get that gun for free now if you
want ah
might as well if you want a decent
machine gun although I kind of like the
combo we have zone now where I take out
that machine gonna have on you took take
the right way I don't think I want it
but well you can sell it I think for
this mission
alright smart Christus oh [ __ ] those
[ __ ] alien pods what doing those
those dudes bugs the ones they kinda
remind me the ones from before that drop
the em my god there's the alien covenant
yet no I'm not going to see it in
protest why um
I'm one of the people who think that
Prometheus was one of the worst movies
ever and I saw the reviews of covenant
and Adam Sessler told me that it was the
worst movie he's ever seen since
Armageddon Wow
hey that's not to me that even movies oh
there's red urban oh that's a nozzle to
me because Adam Sackler Center movie uh
said this is that it would rain yeah
it's not that it was some time ago he
said it was the were things I needed to
get out more than um I'll call it if
he's watching this solvers gross
exaggeration only said that you can it's
not the worst movie it's actually like
the third best family movie in my
opinion it's not a great movie but it's
good
but I mean go take Adam steps Woodward
for everything and cry about it
you just know what so what's your order
then uh alien aliens and covenant I
haven't seen three in like ten years own
I know it's not great but I kind of want
to rewatch it i know david fincher like
swear it like doesn't mention it ever
alright bugs coming up okay I'm ready
they've been birthed out of this pod
holy [ __ ]
he's really close to me I'm coming
running
[ __ ] these things they have so much oh
yeah you got to shoot the [ __ ] thing
my body that one now this one now the
chest
and why wait wait left hand when we
actually pay attention is a weak spot
that's correct you have to shoot their
weak points for maximum damage uh you
your health is not alike no it's not but
I'm okay
uh yeah Leonard pull that leave hair
okay these [ __ ] things that grab you
so what did you think of prometheus I
didn't like it um I serious I probably
didn't from EPA yeah you're not you're
not going to love covenant but I think I
mean from what it sounds like you
probably better off waiting till it's
like on demand or something
i I don't everybody's entitled to their
opinion but I don't think it's nearly on
uh yeah that's why I went down first
what happened it's dumb human corpse
okay really multiple ones are gonna grab
me coming they're not even hurting me
they're just like I'm on the rail so
thank you rollin rap [ __ ] scared the
crap out of me
damn oh this is really infuriating I was
last to get pushback pervert well I
laughs anyway I guess
but yeah I don't like prequels in
general I wish Prometheus and covenant
did not exist because because Prometheus
was the setup for a trilogy so covenant
is the first in a trilogy of movies you
know that I heard that was their
intention yeah the Prometheus was just
matter I don't like how they have to
explain everything like especially in
covenant yeah I wasn't anyways the
origin I was also told because I was
like gimme spoilers free things of what
you didn't like and what you did like
and they were like in terms of things
that they really didn't like one of the
biggest problems oh my god oh [ __ ] yeah
playing around was how much the movie
explain things to you
it's a oh it's how mode realize how much
it explains every kind of like you're
like you're dumb yeah there are some
cool ideas in it but I don't think they
really want with them
there's we're leaving a lot of stuff
back here I know there's not much I can
do about it I have a lot of ammo sorry
hold on I'm just trying to see if no
actually here okay hear me out
give me I'm going to give you my shotgun
rounds uh okay
hopefully you can take all of them I I
only can take this mean [ __ ] oh that was
no point to that then no I mean I got
more shotgun rounds yeah you should take
these flame round stuff I know I should
but I can't okay I'm saying we should
trade off and we'll you mean it alright
um Scott you have egg you could get rid
of the egg no I refused he never
promised in egg Ron I'm not sure I
believe on I didn't promise mega I have
like 217 time we never discussed it we
definitely yeah well I chose to and
people expect me to follow through
because I'm a man of my word I could get
rid of this gun knows that's not in the
long run that's not I have four guns
okay but selling a sorrowful is worth
more than these flame rounds um oh right
I think since you know what I know what
I'm gonna
no [ __ ] it nevermind just leave them I
don't care mm-hmm
goodbye flame rounds this will be
helpful though come on okay so why can't
I press this button
mm-hmm come on there we go oh I have to
be on the right one that's dumb that's
my good side but this cutscene can
happen because they didn't make one with
sheva on the left sweet this is the boss
we've made progress we know how to kill
this guy we [ __ ] up last we have [ __ ]
output I'm actually glad that we get to
redo this only for this because we
couldn't only we actually process what
to do we just kept hitting him with a
flamethrower and I thought if you did
that like enough times it would die but
it didn't and the job it's the tail weak
spot that opens up that we didn't see
right
well glad you're making fella up here
you you're hot but you're annoying
myself
we're still June June June you like it
broken record Winona just as
single-minded as he said this fence
along fun to trap download overdose will
here enjoy mister or borrow where is
Jill a lock we kill him can I have
dinner with you nobody is getting you
and you're planning on selling it to
Paris falling for example to be able to
save from the progenitor virus I have no
intention of getting it in heaven then
what are you using it for
you'll find out soon enough
everybody's the first stone one that was
true through DNA we shall proceed to the
next search my vision and is aligned now
reality evolutionist what are you
talking about this [ __ ] don't know
about evolution she just wants every
human to look like her I'm fine with
next isn't it
everybody's just wearing a halter top
[Music]
[Applause]
only certain ones are kids really come
Stella wait
all right you know with all those
muscles like me okay cool
John's gonna gather some ammo and [ __ ]
there's a lot of health everywhere well
we have time to fly over and and wipe
down all poachy
um I can't take that yet it'll take some
time for the tanks ah so she's the
explosive barrels at the can right now
all right guys coming toward me you want
to get behind my door I did it Oh your
fault now you're gonna draw him over
here start up from the ground he's
better ground coming six feet under come
left up here
actually yeah yeah you're what you're
like getting too close those are selling
you here we go okay you can achieve it
come this way yeah
all right here he comes is gas here yeah
do that
oh he was under the ground no he wasn't
his arm was over there
there we go his arm was coming toward
you and I shop a barrel I'll get a
flamethrower if you want to create a
shoot wait
he's underwater UI ready wait wait
yeah ask you that I'm gonna hit him with
it anyway I think yeah alright good and
then what am i doing shooting the thing
for the weak spots
alright stop fire no you got I mean I
gotta keep you like color expose oh so
they're not excessive nope now they're
shoot those yeah
shotgun might be better up to you Nina
feel like you know [ __ ]
alright I got one no I didn't all right
I didn't go well I'm confused
did you miss what's 7 times I have a
shotgun yeah shotgun Fred's wider so you
more like a hit it didn't work yeah miss
yep yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] oh I haven't send your grenades to
I post one of his exposed small area I'm
going to use these anyway just to get
rid of them so we can whoa
you ready might be ah [ __ ] I wait for
that side you ready yeah
yeah Oh an expose those fall
I forgot the object nothing happened
yeah are you gonna be I thought I was
I'm send out him they are what them
baklava and I understand when we're
involved get exposed
you just got a I'll do this Plainsboro
next time more incendiary uh you've got
this to me
the cleanser okay oh there's in
cinder-gray right here
alright coming maybe in the middle going
get him is nothing quick all right y'all
ready y'all ready
like are they explosion ow I'll top up
the top don't see it like I see this
whole thing that's not the look like
I've got
oh nice you did something what hit one
of them sweet okay so oh [ __ ]
I got retry - quick quick quick quick
dammit
you barely every I got this [ __ ]
thing in all of me oh that's so gross
Yankee creature
make that incendiary again over here
that might help the couples
so I think I am here
got a couple of them I'm going to throw
this kick and yes yes yeah sure
shubao going for ball this is damage
alright alright I'm gonna get the thingy
try to aim for that arm ball okay I
think that's what does it he's in the
ground right now okay
you gotta get yeah yeah yeah
going four-arm ball oh we went
underground I'm get it yeah getting rid
of that behind us Oh
[Music]
underground
oh you [ __ ] me up pretty good hit his
arm exams yeah I got help no I don't
there's first aid over here come over
this way I'm actually going to get rid
of this and put it back
oh I'm very injured they're saying here
when you write on listen well
Oh another incendiary
why isn't just pick up a bowl okay new
service incendiary
[Applause]
arm is exposed oh [ __ ] push it back
I got trapped damn you loosing tortoise
you know get a flamethrower people yeah
are you ready sure
[Music]
where is it where's it fall as I said oh
they're out they're out yeah yeah yeah
yeah I only got one sorry Roger oh oh
[ __ ] can it be okay if I can get one
more out again I got out of all nice I
think this one Marit three I don't
understand the arm thing I think you can
just literally shoot those I think
you've regrows them but I think you can
make him less dangerous in the meantime
I shouldn't know oh [ __ ]
well no I don't know how I'm gonna get
there I'm sorry but we did it pulled off
sight again
yeah we like the long ass bar fight all
right ready up um so you had your needs
more
yeah useful yeah use those when his
things come out when is sorry when is
awful things are closed
yeah that's the same type of file women
and wiped out Alpha Team I got into
Sunday arms hand starts [ __ ] my early
need them
there goes an arm yeah I think that's
actually the best gun for the job
because you can shoot a lot oh yeah
shoot a lot of balls got them you want
you that canister oh [ __ ] in fact uh yep
come on [ __ ] oh yeah
put your left stick when you get a
chance I know that's not your part oh
right I don't even notice it
all right I got it son very good
okay oh yeah they're balls are out so
saying oh they're so quick yeah so we
just did damage ah [ __ ] i weights that I
think did I dancing
Hey Oh No
I got the barrel in the middle yeah he's
that barrel too can hang basic
flamethrower oh he's over here he's next
to this one I'll get this
nice sweet all right arm is exposed all
right you got exposed the arm things
ministry pop out on top oh oh [ __ ]
where'd he go
maybe not monogrammed do damage to him
and then he dies at some point things
come out no no you guys shoot the star
three things he's gotta like do enough
[ __ ] to him so he comes out as a Jenelle
all right you ready yes
[ __ ] wait I thought I'd have more yes I
wouldn't the rifle you need to tear that
up shoot oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] and heavy innit
oh whoa I got a recheck yeah
oh my god
[ __ ] incendiary 300 I jump over them
oh [ __ ] but um I did not realize he was
that close to me coming sweet look at
the flamethrower you ready with that
made launcher ah yeah oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's not I stabbed him
[Music]
all right even balls out now to choose
our favorite yeah do that don't need to
worry about aiming without you yeah
they're out there out there out you know
seen aa
together up
we're getting oh there's a barrel of a
girl yeah there is still a barrel all
right I'm so that's plane left yeah I'm
on
we can easy at luck I got to recharge
not a lot like for how things grow
oh man are you gonna die can you get
over here
resuscitate me I'm trying oh I got first
aid with the [ __ ] out of here
sorry hey did you stop dying chill out
about them up here there you go
yeah I gotta wait the flamethrower it's
on the ground over there - got it
oh the knocking yeah good question
some music is still happening oh my god
did we break it I don't know I'm gonna
get the flamethrower in case the game
decides to work oh my god
all right you're stressing me out I
don't want to do it again we might have
to where did he go
get on the floor get out here you [ __ ]
like the music is
[Music]
crazy we might have to wait my god
[ __ ] we broke it
what happened well was it because he was
gonna kill you and I resuscitated you
like at the perfect time
don't know cuz that's the last thing I
might have to kill yourself in a grenade
launcher or something err wait
yeah um tell yourself we're enabled no
no no go back from checkpoint no you're
right sorry I thought that said yeah
restart game point yes
oh that [ __ ]
keep having to do this [ __ ] ready up
yeah how many times are we alright look
at those resent me and I already have a
couple here
like yeah
rook
I don't know if it does that do anything
if you don't if you've not hit by blame
I know not you're wasting a lot of
soccer and so here I got some incendiary
beer all right what yeah we've got to
keep doing that kind of damage so now
grenade launched that [ __ ] I wasn't
running
I just oh no oh [ __ ] I just wasted them
right he's right neck to a barrel has it
I never mind everything what the [ __ ] is
room all right somehow you got out I
work that well you sounded really no I
didn't do anything
all right it's a grenade launchers ready
he's coming for me
nope not even close laughing okay yeah
yeah
show your Baldy [ __ ]
there they are
thank you
oh I think they stay out until you do
enough damage
honestly oh they didn't go in for a
while at kind until you hit him just
like it's frustrating because sure yeah
I think he's right behind me
no my son he's on the other side it's
frustrating cuz bring up this place
[ __ ] again coming after me that
community ready on the phone
Shannon had them where I can saw the
barrel he's right next to it
not yet I go I heard all right get the
point Sarah then I got his arms he's in
the center that Nader out [ __ ] him
so mr. ball yeah there
the job
alright backing out
get over to me I will use the first day
oh don't I didn't get it
[ __ ] sorry nevermind screw that I'll get
it a second don't worry bout [ __ ]
alright you coming over the barrel down
there quick and keep the barrel for me
I'm gonna play drone quick
I they ought nobody's got to hit us l
got the in it sorry there's not much you
could do against that attack really come
I gotta go refill about winter I'm gonna
get that first aid get that first aid
first inhale because you're we're going
to do well I got to put the flamethrower
back I got to figure out what's going
and you like distracted or something I
don't know what to get rid of
oh for God's sake Mary shoot at them
that's out I literally can't stabbing a
tan
get behind get away go go go go I can't
move while the reload animations
finishing but thank you for the alert
all right trying to make you not die
again that's all
hi sweetie got enough for you want to do
points I've spent yeah I want you to
heal first
I know Mary I'm on the appetizer man
you're getting frustrated in his arias
annoying me oh man you got to deal with
this [ __ ]
you're like such a bird right next to
you that's fine it's okay you need to
like top doing with your good side you
you let go I can go first days pray
right now I'm going in govern if you
keep Hey
if you kicking winning I'm not getting
it look you're the one who's complaining
well you're being a really difficult to
work with right now look guess what I
just used by myself hey Bob I have me
the first date for you you're just like
I'm not I don't want to do this boss
fight again and I need you to like help
out okay
I'll get the first date decide he's
making us fight amongst ourselves
no you're making it by eye or by an
assault it's your kind of being an Ariel
I'm like I'm out using that until you
apologize no oh that sucks I'm gonna go
use by myself get away from me apologize
no just luck can be like the worst
episode ever good you know
other than it no apologize first no your
I'm gonna shoot you [ __ ] this is
fit-out you are annoying the viewers
right now oh my god you're trying so
hard
alright I'm just gonna kill them okay
actually I don't let you to [ __ ] touch
me
come here some of it now apologize life
health
I'll just get a fine no no you're good
oh yeah good call heads up oh hi Mon I'm
good whatever
yeah oh you do nothing again god damn it
let's [ __ ] attack oh wait I got
incendiary oi did should i saw some
earlier
yeah yeah come on falls out Jesus you're
almost there though I can't really do
much yeah yeah yeah hey go there go
there out there out there yeah oh my god
ha ha ha ha ha there we go
don't even apologize what happened
sooner oh my god I would never apologize
to you not for that to stubborn people
is the worst combination ever but we
would beat him one stubborn person one
stubborn ass sweet I will call it an
episode sure sweet okay cool I'm going
to make sure that the audio worked
before we yeah might call it a night who
knows we'll see maybe let's finish this
episode all right cool wait wait that
was weird Oh cuz we did chapter select
to get back there oh no I said endgame
I'm curious actually I'm gonna go see
which where we're at we are at next one
is the tunnels go run ship deck research
facility it seems about right
can I fix one ship deck if you go back
one on yours here where you can do it
online so you can see it wait one is so
here's the chapter select four we walk
in here but then we [ __ ] share um oh
what about cuz like here's the thing
look where's what about the jail thing
when is the jail thing happened see on
ship deck yeah cuz see how we have two
times is that what it is yeah but is
that because we did both yes but I'm
asking you when is the Geo site on this
chapter I don't know yeah I guess that's
right confusing huh
go to list goes one good left somewhere
huh all right well maybe it's on ship
deck I guess sweet we're getting toward
the end we're getting there
all right cool oh sweet all right we'll
see everybody next week or whatever this
next episode goes up yeah you'll have to
end the episode though right do some
witty banter well they're not bored I
thought that was your job yeah me too
but I thought what if I came back and it
said nothing was recording I would not
do these again yeah I've done them twice
now we would do it for our viewers be
out route I know what I'm doing I didn't
I don't know I don't know you're just
mad because I didn't seem like you did
still pissed off that wasn't first I am
pissed EW but you're still wrong in this
I tried to end the episode feel like
you're going to actually yell at me I
mean I don't think that's the kind of
person I would I don't think that's what
I would do but I'm not like pray for me
viewers you know not I'll do it this way
I don't feel great about you right now
[Music]